欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
节目一直提醒大家
升息的锅盖拿起来的话
我们即将迎来一个开开心心的光辉十月
以及第四季
今天盘面似乎就迫不及待了
越涨越多
中场上涨了890几点
而且贵买今天足足上涨了3.6个百分点
哇今天算是一个百花齐放
体感温度非常好的一天哦
昨天我们说下上一线涨一半
大家半信半疑
今天似乎连成交量都来到了一兆以上
好到底有没有什么事情值得留意呢
其实像今天台币是升值的
因为外资大买台股也是将近900亿元
整个半导体上中下游
几乎都有涨停的代表作
难道跟黄仁勋的一句话说
明年的金片销售要翻倍有关
还是有什么样我们没有看到的契机跟商机
现在进场还来得及吗
因为今天收收在47000点以上
好下个礼拜的布局格外重要
因为礼拜五是中秋节廉价开始
四个交易日要做哪些事
今天一起告诉您来欢迎来宾
第一位是盈利投资的中国中
中总
好中总要提醒大家
有一个很关键的事情是
台湾央行没有升息哦
日央升息 美央升息
欧央升息 窝门没升息
代表什么呢
代表我们的环境很宽松啊
企业要融资成本是低的
是根本大放水的一个环境
但钟大胆也要提醒大家
下个礼拜四个交易日
我们先不要急哦
我们先来看
第一他很在意MSCI的动态哦
过去历年都一定有代表做
这一次会拱谁
今天独家猜猜看哦
告诉你谁会脱颖而出
再来有一个廉价了
所以不妨布局一些
有高值利率的廉价消费股
等到下礼拜有一天
钟大胆说积极进场
等一下告诉您
第二位是我们的
国家级基金操盘手
黄丰凯哥
凯哥来也要讲
哇我今天半导体好帅哦
上中下游
都有人大涨
甚至唱历史新高
是因为任勋哥的一席话吗
是因为下个礼拜
有台积电的技术论坛吗
等一下把理由告訴您
但關心投信的動態
前陣子真的比較保守都買了很多金融股風向現在吹囉等一下邦尼獨家見證投信買了哪一些從金融轉AI的裡面不少叫做CPO
CPO的延續力
等一下凱哥也來告訴您
好第三位是我們的籌碼專家
全證小哥
好各位來講
這禮拜的鬼故事好多
那當然其中一個就是
銅箔機版三雄的故事
今天籌碼有沒有轉好
或是到底整體PCB籌碼的狀況呢
哥幫您做掃描了
但是他有提到
看起來資金有從PCB
稍微轉到哪裡去
封測股
今天封測股的表現
非常強勁
晶圓電還漲停板
好 到底主力有沒有布局封測
答案是有的
以及會告訴您
掃出來第四季
能夠續強的主投買
好股票喔
好 首先有請鍾娜達安
鍾娜好
好 再次恭喜您出書
排行榜上居高不下
謝謝 謝謝
大家趕快搶喔
好 但是我們的央行厲害了
連石洞
本來大家都覺得這次要升
結果沒有
你覺得這在醞釀一個大放水行情
今天幫我們看MSCI
這一次會拱出來的
以及廉價的消費股
是 我們先來看今天上場
大多數的國家都是上漲
我覺得最主要還是在這兩天
各國的貨幣政策
也陸續都已經把底牌都揭曉出來了
我們先來看台灣
楊金龍的部分
這邊昨天提到過
維持2%不變 連石洞
那CPI今年2.03
明年2%以下
所以他說
目前我們不跟著美國
做一個升息動作
那今年的GDP
會上去到11.48
坦白講他這個部分
已經也暗示了一些
一些想法
我的猜測
就是央行創造低利率的環境
而且我認為說
下次12月份
升息的理由應該不高
為什麼
因為這次他已經講說
明年CPI會有2%以下
所以這次不升息
那下次呢
那更沒有理由要升息
所以換句話說
也就是說變相的一個資金寬鬆
那日央呢
也接著今天也宣布了朝生意
因為最主要是
8月核心的通膨放緩到1.7%比預期低
日元不過我們上禮拜已經提到過了
他沒有在做升值
表示什麼
就是準備要貶了
對這種升息的態度的想法
已經大概已經打了預防針
不過我要特別強調一下
這個已經來到157
這條線叫連線
連線代表就是一個中長期的趨勢
換句話說這次已經反映這一塊的部分換句話說下個禮拜應該日幣的部分有可能會再做生殖的部分同樣上個禮拜我們跟大家提到過央行
我發現我跟央行真的一樣
我們說31塊半會來到32
32又要準備要再生殖
這幾天又生殖下去
所以你只要把那個抓好之後
其實上外資也在做這樣的動作
那我們先來看這禮拜的行情部分
我們怎麼看
坦白講我還是會認為是高出
像這禮拜我個人在操作的話
我禮拜二 禮拜三
霸盤大跌到四萬五千多點
那很好機會
那今天就開始要做
自當做一月鮮馬 為什麼
這個禮拜大家如果看
今天的盤好像是不錯 興高採烈
但這個禮拜的量是3.77兆
創下新低量
而且還加上0050盤後的生效
如果沒有這個量
那量還更低
這是六月份以來的新低量
那下禮拜應該還會更新低量
因為下禮拜不連價效益
當時我上禮拜提到過
這禮拜是一個關鍵週
什麼叫關鍵週
它會決定後面的後半個月
到底是要強還是弱
那最後面是上漲
表示這個部分的下半個月
會維持一個叫高檔的成立
也就是說已經不太會一個弱勢格局
跌到很低的位置去
那短線支撐會看45,200
收盤在47,000以上的不多
那今天收盤盤有在47,000
我個人認為說下禮拜
一不用考慮太多
禮拜一就先高出 然後再低接
等到什麼低接
等到禮拜四大家去放假的時候
要賣的時候你再來接
8月31號的大量1.2兆
我上次提到過
4548點很重要
上次有提到過
那這波這禮拜最低點就是45398
換句話說這個不被MFCI的這個
當然天的大量
確實是很重要的參考點
所以我覺得這個位置
45000應該是附近是
近期比較重要的參考位置點
不過唯可惜就是
90KD43不上不下
也沒有拉到很低
也沒有很高
所以就很尷尬
不過因為我認為說
現在有個不確定性很高
是因為包括今天美國
還有個四五日結算
下個禮拜有不少國家要放長假
你看今天的日本沒漲很多
相對台灣 日本 韓國
這幾個國家比
因為下禮拜日本要休秋分日
開始要休好幾天
還有一個川喜會
所以我個人會是
長假前最後一天買劑就是至少有那個賣壓的部分你可以去做借因为你今天去买礼拜一礼拜二就有人要卖尤其是礼拜二就是中秋节
资金要抽回的最后一天
我换句话说礼拜一你不卖
礼拜二一定会能卖
那因为连长三天了
所以我个人觉得这部分是
礼拜一不用考虑
有高档先做卖掉
等什么时候
等到大家卖的时候
你再来做地界动作
长假消应大家担心
反而我们要勇敢
那另外一個因素是因為什麼
上規市場上的法人後半週
你各位看一下
我一直講叫OTC
OTC這個是大家看法人的所謂
它現在來到近期的新低
換句話說你現在看上市是大買
但是OTC它卻是把它做一個
在節前或是在這段時間把它賣掉
換句話說看起來是這部分
還是有點擔心的部分
所以我個人是認為說
如果有這樣的情況的話
那這個位置來到47000以上
我認為是說不用去做追
你今天買的不用去做追
但是第四季的行情不錯
所以下禮拜如果拉回來的時候
你再去做一個買進
短期的資金
日量不會過照
投資本說今天不會過照
沒有每天有0050的
所以今天0050的盤後生效要扣掉
只有8000多億
短線的一定做短衝
這個如果你是做短線的
你可以再衝來衝去
中線的你就可以報過節
安心的過 因為中秋節
你就不管川普講什麼
跟習近平講什麼話
你都跟我們沒關係
反正你就抱著這些股票
至少可以安心的過日子 對
來看一下美國的走勢
道瓊這波最高
但是這波已經殺下來
到這個位置半連線
而且季線下彎
上升趨勢線法是什麼
這個走勢已經
原本強的已經變弱了
原本弱的像台積電ADIR
或貴城半導體是
原本最弱現在開始變強
轉強
已經告訴你一件事情
市場上已經開始慢慢
從藍籌股已經轉到科技股去了
換句話說這個風向已經
在醞釀說第四季應該慢慢會
慢慢主導在這一塊部分
所以我想這個告訴你
這個進擊的趨勢是有這樣的現象
好 那來看一下
MRC在新增的成分股
上次新增的是最強是台虹
再來是順德
其實到順德最近還是很強
那看起來目前
因為我認為說
MCA每次都會有代表作
我長期追蹤
所以到目前我幫大家做追蹤
大概目前比較排名在前幾名的
我看一下目前的
走市比較好 包括雍字科
好 雍字科
對 這是高價位的
好 那這個現行加創反彈的新高
這個你可以等拉回
因為它這個上升趨勢
看起來是很明顯的
當然給我待會凱哥
願意多補充
待會後來講
凱哥可能會投他
因為它這個部分看起來
半導體的一個測試介面的部分
看起來在目前是
這裡面幾家當中
它是算是目前走得最強的部分
不過因為價格比較高
所以節潛如果有拉回
我認為是說可以考慮這個位置
那另外一個叫中價位的
就京均
我京均有上次講過
這個性價比算是比較
這幾家公司算是比較好
不過因為最近的這個PCB的材料
雜音有
雜音有難免就會有看多的
也有看不好的
所以會互相削減
我個人覺得如果可以的話
如果有壓回也可以追討留意
因為它最近的籌碼是有點會比較
沒有像這個那麼好
那麼穩定
那機器人呢
這個低價位的盟利
我上次有提到過了
那這個部分它最近
有拉回到這個季線附近
有守住
我個人覺得如果這塊
機器人長期的方向是OK的話
我覺得這個部分倒是
也是可以留意
我跟你講分高價位跟中價位
低價位投資本就去做觀察
那另外還有一個也不錯
和聲堂
但是因為最近的被動原理
不是那麼起義性的強制
大致上原則上這四家公司
目前是看起來是
最有機會的
最有機會
但我會陸續觀察
我會在節目當中
仔細做觀察的部分
是 好 但是接下來的話
有廉價的效應
還是先建議大家
要把握這種廉價裡面
消費的概念股
我會挑幾家公司
一個就是內需
過幾個四天你會去哪邊
你一定是去內需消費
或還有第四季 犒賞自己
那出國就長榮航空
或者你當然現在飛機找進去買好
但是問題是接下來是11機車
要出國像小哥也要出國
類似這樣子 大家也都要出國
我也是要出國
你也是 你們剛剛在討論
我有聽到
是啊 那新光金跟台信新光金
跟中信金就是
這個銷金的信用卡的部分
坦白講他們目前的EPS的部分
看起來銀行股不錯
那這個殖利率
我大概預估了它明年來講
到目前應該這些
都有4 5%左右 算還不錯
所以我先講一家公司
先講我們就從中信
中信金
會講這家公司
是因為我個人覺得
前陣子的金融股漲得滿多的
它倒是漲得比較慢那我們想想看為什麼長得罵因為後來他公布他的上半年的EPS大概將近兩塊然後連增將近有317%前8月份的稅後他們有
後來有製結的部分大概2.7
那今年EPS有機會挑戰4.3元
所以我如果算一算的話
他EPS這樣算起來的話
他大概明年股力應該有3塊錢
那你看1塊1塊8 2塊3 2塊半
明年有機會3塊
其實他的股息值率大概是4.2左右
那股利延續年年成長
淨值大概35塊
因為大家看我會看銀行
都是看股息殖利率
但是不要忘記
它一個Bull value非常重要
它的淨值裡面相對
我看也是算是在銀行裡面當中
是比較高的部分
所以我從這幾個角度來看一下
這家公司
其實股價很強勢
它很強勢
但是最重要的是
你不要買乖利太高的
你看它這邊一直打底打很久
最近開始走比較強
為什麼
最近的外資跟投信開始買
尤其投信大概在9月初開始買
你看投信的成本
很明顯這樣切下去就知道
投信的成本就跟現在價錢差不多
那來看一下這邊套勞量不會很多
因為大概成交量多是成交在這附近
我們如果就是他目前是受限到
他的歷史最高價73.6元
但如果把它還原全值
還原息值
其實他已經創下歷史新高
而且MACD即將這個州的部分
即將有可能會創向上交叉
所以我個人認為說
如果未來第四季是消費的旺季
那這些消金為主的
我個人覺得倒是可以去留意一下
因為很少看到外資跟投信
最近開始買這些所謂
剛期漲的部分金融股
我想這個應該是可以留意的部分
另外一個就是遠東百貨
它的大巨蛋遠東Garden City
8月22號開幕
是台北最大的
北部最大的百合公司
坦白講它的頻數算大
董作委說明年挑戰北區的業績王
也因為這個位置
也因為它開幕後來
我真的實際去考察一下
我真的上禮拜我去看一下
有些點真的還沒
店面還沒完全擺下去
因為那個是大電
就是國際的那種
國際品牌有些還沒入進
但是後來陸續都進去了
重點也是你看
它過去的
我們看它營業了
開始從5月6月份開始這邊
逐漸增加
如果一般人都很清楚了
母親節那檔完之後
接下來就是檔季了
它的營餘率很重要的是創新高 毛利率也創新高百合公司毛利率 盈喻率創新高不容易因為現在說的賣
坦白講都是營業也都是會有限
但是只能在管銷費用控管
所以我們會發現
其實它每年的獲利是滿穩定的
今年看起來是上半年的獲利
好像比之前來的衰退多
所以主要是因為中國大陸那邊
有做一個業外的儲置的部分
那他股息殖利率坦白講
每年都有一塊左右的股利的部分
那股息 禁值大概22塊
大概目前股進比是在1%左右
所以如果順起來的話
他的殖利率大概有4.5左右
好 那我們來看他股息要走勢
最近都一直在整理
那小編問我說
中總你為什麼要把它放那麼長的時間
對 為什麼要放這麼長呢
因為放那麼長就是要很對照啊
就6 7 8月也是這樣子
那11月呢
會突然 對
因為什麼
你11月10號公佈
營業的就是那個什麼
週年慶的旺季
你看起來是
遠東百貨已經在這禮拜
已經開始週年慶了
那未來是
就還是一樣
你就是想
未來是消費旺季是這樣走
還是消費旺季是這樣走
你自己去抓
但我個人是覺得
禁止不貝留是22塊錢
看起來目前大概在位置
所以各位去參考
如果未來週年慶來的時候
應該是有機會
往上來做一個反應
这边提供大家做参考
就中总去考察啦
但是接下来中总联系
也要贡献喔
我还要去考察看看
才能让他这样嘛
对不对
要实际花钱喔
是是是
好
这边非常谢谢中总
谢谢赵华
好 中大长要提醒大家
哇我们央行
跟别人都不一样
我们连十栋喔
对于国内的资金环境
是真的给予比较宽松的
这是一件好事情
但是毕竟下个礼拜有廉价喔
所以资金在这段时间
如果已经有赚到一些钱的
可能下个礼拜一会
会做一些些调节
不过如果廉价钱还有再压回的话
就要把握了
因为刚刚有讲到
即将迎来所谓的光辉十月
那这边的话MSCI帮您猜一猜
讲出四档股票
看您喜欢哪一档
那至于喜欢比较稳健的
刚刚也讲到消费长假的parking股
在这边殖利率保底
那广告回来呢
我们的凯哥要上场了
凯哥也要讲
哇塞今天半导体的上中下游都这么赞
他会怎么看
再來投現的風也在轉喔
從金融股慢慢的轉到一些AI股
而CPU的延續力看來非常厲害喔很多人常問我現在幫小孩子唇股還來得及嗎我都說存股當然要而且越早越好如果能夠定期定額以年花報酬率8%來估算的話
負利累積下來
在孩子18歲的成年
都會擁有第一桶金
那以我台金專家的角度來說
我會提醒各位爸媽
我們還有一個比存股更加
穩賺不賠的終身投資
答案就在孩子
關鍵的黃金成長期
存未來
以這個莊廣核糖轉大人來說話
當然是我唯一推薦
他不但是市場上轉大人的龍頭品牌
更有百萬家長的信任
更厲害的來了
他還有三胞胎
親生實證
是看得到成果的品牌
這就是台灣第一位女中醫
莊淑琦博士幫曾孫三胞胎
轉大人配方的實力
第一次答得好
未來在學業職場上
就像買到復國神山台積電一樣
潛力無窮
莊廣核糖轉大人
為孩子的未來超前部署
好 今天手上有半導體股票的朋友
一定挺開心的
可是心裡面也會有點毛毛的
如果又還來不及
在這段時間上車的
凱哥也要來分享
事實上有些股票
就算今天大漲還是相對便宜
我發現中總在你前面
都會先幫你塞一個梗
等你來接
對啊
好像不跳進去不行
好 我們先來看
任兴哥說明年的晶片要翻倍了
當然營收都要成長70%了
所以大大應該要來台灣
來等一下幫我們聊這個
頭線也在轉了
從金融股開始轉到像CPU
或是半導體股了
是 我們現在解一下中董長
這個MHCI
你要知道
MHCI基本上它要考量到
流通性的問題
對 不是市值到就可以了
它考量流通性問題
所以剛剛那三檔
我個人覺得
可能短線
就會長的可能是雍智
你看
但是會納入MACI的可能是盟利
對 我剛才講嘛
因為要考量到流通性的問題
因為他剛剛點名之後
我就特別看了一下佣智
今天外資大敲佣智
所以感覺不太單純
而且他最近的買超大戶
今天又大買
所以我說他可能是
會漲得比較兇的
但是會納入MACI的
可能會是盟利
2464的盟利
所以我等於是
替中華膽選了一檔股票
他上禮拜也選這檔
我投了盟利
是 你們兩個不要在那邊
親民相通了好嗎
這樣我們看我們自己的
接下來就是黃倫勳講說
2027年的機面現在要增加一倍
所以他讓大家吃一顆
因為之前大家擔心說
AI可能要開始什麼 踩煞車了
但是告訴你說什麼
它要從476一直跳到1080
未來6G要大幅的成長
而且這裡面其實看到一個很重要的關鍵
就是細光子
因為細光子其實未來怎麼樣
未來才會到位 2028年
所以你現在在講什麼
AI會造成人類的滅絕什麼
其實看科幻片比較快一點
現實是沒有那麼快
所以這樣講之後
剛剛講之後今天怎麼樣
今天整個大盤就
整個AI
暴動
這不是被動 是暴動
而且今天以這個台積電的子弟兵
創意 率先 創新高
而且最近投心一直在買
所以他今天是
應該講今天是重中之重
沒有什麼問題
第二是聯電
聯電是今天漲得比台電還要多
而且這一波 頭信也大買
結果我們看到產物設備的裡面
材料的中砂裡面也亮燈
然後散熱的高麗跟雙紅也紛紛亮燈
那這個部分可能
大家比較關心是台達
不過台達還在
緩步的在慢慢的墊底的這個部分
所以我們等一下再來看
好 那我們來看
我們之前有講過雙紅
雙紅我說
頭信還沒領情
外資已經開始買了
後來頭信就開始回來買
股價也怎樣也就拉上去了
這是週型態喔
週型態是已經過了前面的高點的位置
而且它距離前高一步之遙
所以它今天有點稍微
尾盤有點稍微被壓一下
但是我覺得看起來還會繼續往上走
那你看到買賣超的部分是
17000多張對3900多張
所以看起來還是一個買方的趨勢
沒有什麼改變
但是它在漲的時候
它就會把齊鴻
建設這個族群通通都帶上來
因為他們算是一整個族群的股票
它不會是單一檔
中砂比較尷尬
因為它是金貝
金貝供電裡面除了它以外
還有另外一種就是8028
森陽辦也有這一塊
可是森陽辦比較多是再生金源
所以它就會受到
再生金源這塊的市場的影響
所以它相對來講
可能就沒有表現那麼漂亮
你看這是中砂的部分
基本上投心也是大買
投心也大買
而且你看這是州的型態
州的大量高就在這裡
之前拉回來整理完之後
就噴出去而且今天是爆大量符合總統講的這個大量要小心一點當然要小心一點今天反而是要比較小心嗎對 因為爆大量其實投信沒有買那麼多
我投信沒有買
而且外資今天是稍微減碼的方向
所以創高後反而我們要注意一下
對 所以不見得是
創高就一定要去追
我們來看一下最近投信在幹嘛
投信最近因為要升息
所以他們相對於比較保守
他們就買超比較多的金融股
可是我們從他們在買超的部分
我們看到有一些AI的電子股
AI的電子股 例如說像聯電
例如說像什麼
廣達 強茂 南亞
這是相對來講他們在大盤
在弱勢的情況之下
還是比較積極在佈局的
這個AI電子股
在上櫃的部分
你可以看到
他們就沒有什麼金融庫可以買了
就買比較多的什麼的電子股
這裡面有一些是買上去的
有一些是壓下來的
例如說 奇邦是買上去的
我記得富橋應該也是買了
幾個禮拜了
基本上還停在這個地方
那像這個光潔是被動元件
心犬是封測
對 那其實這邊還是有一些是
比較偏保守的
例如說像星象這些
就比較偏殖利率
這邊還有聯亞
所以我們可以看到這個族群裡面
其實有一個很隱藏的題材
就是CPO
CPO就是像聯亞 奇邦
其實這都綁著CPO在繞
其實心犬也是
因為它也是比較偏
CPU的測試的部分
所以其實如果你說
在這個CPU測試有兩家
就是齊邦加星全
所以告訴你其實
CPU還是目前的重重之重
重重之重
好 接下來看的是
最近投信一直在買的聯電
大復活了
對啊 我之前不是在笑嗎
我說什麼
投信拼命的賣
對不對
可是他現在卻慢慢往上
我說外資怎麼樣一直狂買
對 外資是狂買
那所以講說台積電
產能溢出來的部分
因為在成熟製程的部分
台電不積極 他是把它溢出來了
那台電的產能
成熟製程就交給世界先進
那還有一部分就到聯電來
那聯電今天會漲
還有跟一個有關係
就是他也要跨入CPU
是 他要跨入CPU
所以最近這個投信就猛買
大復活聯電到貨
但是其實如果你看
買賣券商其實感覺不太出來
對耶 打平而已
打平而已
但是因為我們的投信怎樣
就是猛買
所以他是從原本的負轉正
投信買兩萬八
1萬1這樣買
而且看起來它就快要逼近前高了
對啊
逼近前高在這裡在這裡但是它高點有大量所以要努力一下對不對所以接下來它可能就要進入震盪的位置震盪的位置所以不見得說我們今天在講
你就立刻
下禮拜就第一個時間要買
其實稍微看一下形態
結果在講說
有切入CPO的測試的部分的齊邦
它也是之前有殺過來
這股災好慘
那也現在算中衛節
那你看它的大量
基本上在這裡
大量快要碰到了
所以他下禮拜就要表态了
好
下禮拜就要表态了
但是看起來會不會成功
會喔
投信超通常
因為投信跟外資都是站在買方
對
投信在外賣
而且你看這個買賣超大部分
5萬多對4萬5千多
看起來是一副會上去的樣子
是
因為你看這兩個都是外資喔
都是外資
所以你其實說是投信在買
倒不如說
其實外資是在裡面作證
是
對
等於是外資在裡面
互生
也等於前一陣子的風波
應該已經沒事了
好
我們剛才
我們再更早之前有講到
其實這兩家都是屬於聯電集團的
所以媽媽在往前走
基本上子弟平常會跟著我往上走
接下來我們來看到
CPU的主要的股票
就是聯亞
有回檔了
對 聯亞你看這是州的型態
州的大量高在這裡
州的大量低在這裡
所以它等於是回撤了州大量低
好 那日就不用講了
日目前就是卡在這裡
卡在這裡也沒有站上
但是因為我們剛剛講
你州的角度來看
它大量地已經站上了
所以看起來就會慢慢怎麼樣
慢慢墊高往上走
所以它
因為它是CPU的主要股票
所以這個族群要往上推
它一定要往上走
否則這個股票就會上不去
這個族群會下來
那買賣超是比較平均的
買賣超是比較平均的
但是投信還在加碼
好 開始又加碼起來了
所以我覺得
因為我們剛剛講了
因為這個行情
開始從保守轉區基期
尤其我們剛剛說
中秋之後要大買特買
所以看起來
中秋前一天
就要在大買特買
就要買科技股
所以看起來他們就後世看好
那你看
Mavail其實在出手搶產人
因為他在搶這個
矽光子的這個
上游的零化音的晶片
他是從可插拔的地方
間接的跳進NPO的部分
所以這也會導致
我們最近在講
就昨天在講的鬼故事
就是說因為CPU上來了
整個這個CCL會被壓抑
因為相對來講這個路徑是不一樣的
但是這個不是現在這是2028年不是現在所以你現在會不會會講的太早了那你不可能說為了2028年這些高階的財品都不做
都不進步了 不可能
對 沒有辦法
所以它基本上還是
我個人還是覺得還是鬼故事
這個方向比較多
那接著是
我們來看今天整個
細光其實都是漲的
從連電一直到
我們剛剛的齊邦跟新權
其實這一段其實都是漲的
那這裡面今天比較特殊的就是
先前有休息的滑星光
還有像環雨KY
今天就大漲
那最近其實你可以看到
玉金光已經大漲了
今天換大力光開始大漲
因為它又列地了
超猛的
所以其實大家開始
對它又有點期待
因為它最近被外資降頻之後
股價有點稍微下來
好 那我們來看全新
我之前講過了
再回大量高的時候
就是可以參與的機會
所以你看它已經
這個大量高離得好遠好遠
是啊 好強
接著已經馬上要創這個大量高了
對
那這是日線的角度
那還能追他嗎
外資投信還在追啊
投信這兩天竟然還在追
投信還在追啊
雖然外資有點賣
可是還不太理他
為什麼
因為外資本來就買很多了
買了8000多張
那所以投信是不是有一點點慢了呢
算是 算是
因為你看這邊
買賣超的變化
其實是將近兩倍量
將近兩倍量
所以看起來是還會往上走
而且它這個部分感覺有一點
原本的主力賣飛了
主力賣飛了
對 因為過去的全新
有一個Local的主力
就是華南永商桃園
可是它已經被洗掉了
所以接下來就是法輪控盤
不是主力控盤
所以看起來它會繼續往上走
我記得小哥有講過
桃園的地緣分點在買全新
這不是我講的
是小哥已經先講了
因為我們現在要一棒船一棒
大家都要先把坑挖起來
是
他在說這個凱根講過
就不太多講了
這是大家比較少注意到的光環
是
但是感覺也有一點點的什麼
味道出來
其實光環很強這一波
它也有點味道出來了
你看大量在這裡
我們這是從周的大量來看
周大量高是站上
那距離周的大量高
這邊還有一個大量高
稍微量稍微小一點的
目前就在這個中間的地方整理
那日的大量呢
基本上它就卡在這裡了
為什麼特別講它
因為它也是進入CPO的階段
而且其實國內的公司
都是一環接一環
就是像波羅威幫誰代工
誰又幫誰代工
所以我只要講
我說華新光那時候不太好
因為它把聯亞的東西做壞掉了
可是因為市場就是很缺
所以你把東西做壞掉
不代表別人不會給你訂單
所以它就接馬貝爾的訂單
所以它的獲利也跟著上來
為什麼最近投信比較敢積極買華興光
就是實質的數字有出來
它不太是夢的感覺
也比較有數字
你看光環的部分也是一樣
一萬兩千多張
對八千多張
也明顯是買大於賣
所以我覺得它也可以稍微看一下
接著我們看的是龍頭的大力光
是 買地像買菜
對 它最近很積極地在擴廠
可是大家對它的感覺就是
P已經拉很高了
因為其實你獲利也沒有跳很多出來
對 最近出iPhone
其實感覺對它沒有什麼影響
雖然iPhone18最近在熱賣當中
可是我們來看
基本上它也是有特定人在買
8000多張對5700多張
所以表示有人覺得說
它本來的數字就很好了
那你現在因為有細光值
就可以把本益比什麼推高
我們來看它的形態
這是它的大量在這裡
是
然後這邊有一個大量
所以它等於是回撤了這裡
它沒有碰到
你仔細看一下
它的周大量高在這裡
我來畫一下
畫不太出來
有一點點
是大概在這個地方
對
有點接近沒有碰到
但是很妙的是
最近有好多檔的ETF
都要把大地光剔除
為什麼
就是可能覺得他的數字
可能沒有跟上
而且本地比他很高
所以會有點壓力
很難講
為什麼
因為我剛剛講
8000多張對5000多張
對 所以你說投信要賣
而且投信還在買
就是有主
有主
被動的ETF要把它提出來
主動式的
對 有被動式的ETF要提出來
可是主動式的在買
所以這個很尷尬
然後再來就是
你看這個日的大量
日的大量 因為它之前有被降頻
所以它離日的大量有一個距離
所以我覺得到這邊可能會稍微整理一下
也不會立刻噴上去
但是因為最近我觀察到
像郁金光就有特定的阻力在收
所以它就會把整個族群帶上來
而且現在CPU又很夯
所以很難講說
它這邊洗完之後
會不會就直接再往上轉
很難講
所以我覺得還是可以再觀察一下
在這一塊的部分
對 那
你說其實整個族群上面來看基本上其實大立光跟剛剛的族群其實它比較沒有這麼的直接因為它比較算是後面的因為你看它還在買地所以你說它現在大產出
因為它的重點是CPO
你跟像華星光這種
實際上馬上速度就開出來的
是不太一樣的
所以你看投信買的狀況也不太一樣
投信買華星光就是閉著眼睛
幾千幾千在那裡買
可是大力光就是
你看買一買有點縮手
然後又買一買有點縮手
所以我覺得他們相對的走勢應該比較慢
這波會上來我覺得都是少年股神做出來的
了解
就是因為是高價股比較沒有散戶
所以少年股神就很敢在這上面大張旗鼓
是
好 還有高雄的三多哥
再幫小哥挖個坑
這個是小哥
好 所以剛剛講到的投信其實前一陣子真的相對保守
有可能會在第四季趕快回來買
那看來對CPU來說
他們的興趣是高的
數字如果已經開始開出來的
更有興趣了
沒錯
這邊非常謝謝凱哥
謝謝趙滑
好 今天以這個所謂的AI環繞著
真的是開開心心的一天
但凱哥也要講囉
雖然看起來很多公司漲停板
但是還是要稍微區分一下
因為今天很熱鬧
下個禮拜有長假
不妨看一下有一些資金的轉移
例如投信
之前太保守了
都在買進入股也沒錯
因為怕升息
那現在升息的蓋子拿起來了
都開始轉向所謂的AI概念囉
尤其是像CPU
不管是擴散出來的
不管是後段的前段的
只要現在數字稍微能夠開出來
投信是非常喜歡的
不妨先往這個領域做著墨來布局
好 廣告回來
小哥要上場啦
小哥也要講
我們一直在講CZ有兒的鬼故事
那到底籌碼現在在PCB的表現是如何呢
那哥要提醒了
籌碼確實有一點從PCB跑到封測來囉
到底該怎麼抓呢
好 把握割出国前的时间
赶快来看筹码
这个礼拜大家说一天一个鬼故事
但是到了礼拜五
今天开开心心是个神话的故事了
不过我们还是要来解惑
PCB的筹码最近如何
似乎今天风吹到半导体
看来筹码也是如此
昨天有大传特传
CPU如果普及的话
就不要用到M9规格
今天全部纷纷出来澄清
但是到底筹码怎么想的
再來的話 主力買什麼呢
封測股是一個很明顯的族群序長的主力投信都買的有誰好 昨天我回去看籌碼怎麼樣然後就看到台光店變成地板股了
今天已經準備好好的來搶一個
是不是
結果直接開高
開高就沒得搶
好
那因為CCL報降規的鬼故事
對
可是外資送軟了
所以今天其實他們的賣壓都沒了
對 今天都發貪
對啊 鬼故事這樣
第一 傳CPU技術導入
主機板對銅箔機板
CGL規格取求
從M9變成M4
就不需要這麼高規了
不需要這麼高規
直接讓台光電台藥連貌
就殺下來了
可是呢
那法人就說
光通訊全面滲透到這些
SKLout跟SKLout
這個範圖為時尚早
還早了
所以現在全面導入還太早
所以對CGL供應鏈的影響有限
所以看起來沒什麼
業者也說我們那麼努力升級
怎麼可能現在就不搞了
重點他也講說
高階財務升級去世衛兵
M7-M9供不應求
看到供不應求
今天股價就回穩了
台光電是M9進入量產
南亞M7-M8出貨增加
推薦M9是驗證
連貌持續擴充高階產品
所以這些新聞一出來
他們的股價就直穩了
好 那這個外資對台光電
各位看一下目標價
昨天4000多
跌到4000多
結果目標價還是1萬
台光電這個右衣大盤
大摩是8400
那台耀買進
平價買進3000
台耀跌到1200
3000是不是
然後這個大摩說2700
連貿是60
連貿不要接近電
对 那这个
这蓝电锦硕的新机也还不错
是 这载板类的
载板类的
所以这看起来没什么问题
是
好 营幕标价来说当然很远
可是我们需要看一下
筹码现在的状况
那看筹码
这些载板类的
其实筹码是没有很漂亮
板材类目前看起来
真的还好而已
对啊 你看主食主
这个数字也没有很大
有点冷淡
所以呢
這因為昨天的籌碼太差了
所以這個平均下來
就沒有很漂亮你看台光電他在那麼下面對 那麼下面對啊 銅包很爛因為主力大賣它那種跌停一定是主力大賣的
那通常這種大跌
這種大跌的主力大賣
只要出量其實也不用太擔心
就變成有人在搶
對 好 那我們首先來看這個聯帽
那聯帽今天收復黑K
昨天是跌停
然後今天這個小漲一點點
昨天主力大賣 外資大賣
以前說年貌還滿不錯的
其實它這波漲上來
在這邊算是一個高檔震盤整
那高檔震盤整
我們就要看一下
主力這條線有沒有大殺
那昨天看起來是有點恐怖
不過今天就直穩了
那未來就看這下通道有沒有被跌破
假如沒被跌破的話
我觉得还是一个盘整
尖点上应该是9月3号
两个礼拜前帮我们看的
那时候也是说它比较温
是 那尖点的筹码呢
其实长线看起来没有很漂亮
那尖点最近麻烦
怎么样怎么样麻烦
怎么样麻烦
各位有没有看到
它一直有注意喔
那假如一直有注意的话
那像这种股票大概
它就比较难这个大涨特涨
也没什么涨就在注意它
對 現在第六款了
因為現在監獄缺人
現在很缺 真的缺人
以前的刑期很長
以前刑期都10天 12天
現在都是5天跟7天
以前都住6人房
現在都住單人大套房
所以隨便一點事情就注意你要不要來
缺人 很缺人
所以你看
你看他出關兩天就被注意兩天
今天這個沒意外應該也會被注意
只要有量他就會被注意
所以呢在這邊會混呢
可能四五天之後
五天之後又有可能又進關
那如果他有浪子回頭值得留意嗎
像這種很值得留意
像這種各位看一下
他現在是一個布林的大貸款
那布林大貸款就是
他的買一點很好抓
就上軌了你就可以準備賣了
過沒幾天呢
他又要準備聽牌又要被關了
那這時候只要跌到下軌
假如被關的話
跌到下軌又很值得買
好 來回去間操作的好標題
他現在是來回去間操作
蠻不錯的
好 現在看下一個
抬光點
可憐的抬光點
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕